let's say
patience baby you don't build the
biggest building in town
kind of rush instinct watching so many
people make so many short-term
the patients absolutely foundation for
so many people and happiness in
relationships and business you know if
there's anything that I could wish on
the boat
for them to understand that you have
more time at a macro you need to go
faster in the micro day in and day out
faster you're near out and slower
Andy and I are adding people to Team
Gary be around running some of these
Instagram media accounts that we own and
so content creation and growth swipe up
to apply so this book luster device
when's it coming out so you'll come to a
good idea you know what I admire about
you you really really know how to hold
your breath I think the thing that
really makes me me when I talk to myself
about myself to myself that makes me the
most happy is I am able to be a good
person because I'm good at holding my
breath when you're talented you can give
the magnet videos everybody said no he
wants to make somebody video
everybody has mycological Washington I
was in Uganda two months ago and I get
an email that nine three year old man in
a retirement community in Austin watched
it again and he called the oxygen
story inevitably flexi my friend there's
a big difference between building a
brand and Sally
so story right you feel you're building
a brand like you know of course you're
selling on a micro you're branding on a
background that's what I do
I mean idea and I think this is [ __ ]
gross
and I think you can pull it on a man I
think you could pull it off look the
thing that you've done remarkably well
is brand
[Music]
there's something here
this is real yes the area I knew you'd
love it
come pom thank you yes
if this actually happens I want it to be
in the museum one day man so surprising
[Music]
how are you man fine 1% battery life
Wonka said how do you like [ __ ] when I
just emailed you not to read it to be
honest thank God it Dean thank God
because I thought it was a phone call I
was like [ __ ] we missed there we'll have
to reschedule it and in Tyler because it
goes dude the guys here oh my gosh my
god he was like thank you for always I
love it actually you know what I'm not
supposed eat this [ __ ] but cannolis from
Brooklyn and although was achieved a
really well no no no I'm going to make
it one cannolis are like sorry Jordan no
in fact imagine an empanada crossing
each other and oh that kind of like
ricotta cheese
it's okay oh I know what this thing is
this [ __ ] thing is the best the best
bakery in Brooklyn
manager oh thank you man welcome yeah oh
my god who wants to die
sure does anyone it's like died out of
happiness this is so [ __ ] good but I
haven't but again
oh you that always happens with a cream
[ __ ] the Jeff hi can you take this I'm
good
cool how are my friends of course 91
62nd club why do you feel bad
alright take these off everybody 1%
battery life busy no worries ok let's go
over the truth tell me about yourself
I bomb I think that cars my whole life
that I never realized that I'm an
entrepreneur the things that I really I
really that was on my TV show yeah yeah
I remember now
I want the car with Jill to make my
pants my fault applying for it was kind
of raising like know Brooklyn yeah I
know what I know College and handed City
job without me John
listen within local I know like
everybody does again I get it
how are you know I'm 28 Robert so much
time when I was in high school you know
I used to wanna I thought it out on my
super sweet 16 I was 16 years old I see
a dancer an MC four-digit comments
respond when I thought about business
back edge I never looked at it as being
visiting yeah one me someone yeah of
course
so I saw white off pounds caught on
reports my school I was happy you're off
white sands skills but my in her book of
myself is that salt
I knew I want to be something big
graduated college beyond Syria I applied
the Jersey Shore before 10
- oh so and now that's devastating you
know what the show was I know the show
was when that show exploded you were
like [ __ ] and miles don't matter somehow
somewhere if you were so passed right
so ah the show's night on the show was
called the short it was to see a regular
guy from the street make a celebrity
fall for them
so when I was dating from a thousand
people she gets to go in Hollywood I had
30 seconds of game knows like the voice
another rights or all the chance that
was Miss America yeah it was playing in
the year yeah it was
Sophie market I love an electric I love
that this [ __ ] doc is yeah we what do
you say I'm sorry do I say this but I'm
gonna say my thing Yeah right well thing
you kids the one thing I'm good at
yeah that's it for all gorgeous ding
ding ding you'll pick me things like a
common way I love it that's amazing
so I just didn't mean like you're
leaving our kid until I get you a show
it's a high and then a school of yeah so
I haven't seen John's degree get us down
magic is one of them consoles like me I
saw Italy with a lot people died I don't
know I totally understand I do
give me two seconds oh my man I'm going
to throw you in the car with me because
I forgot a Yankee Stadium not right now
what am i leaving ok so let's do the
call right now that you may think cool
yeah and then we'll hang for like 10 15
I'll drop you off in the Bronx
hello how are you sure rather than we
retire here Durbin provided the way to
you for being part is I'm not going on a
bar gonna be like majorities are
endorsing and Williams is dedicated to
this he talked and then there's this
loyalty
don't shine like
[Music]
probably the problem is I think it's a
feature not a platform
you are so gifted in emotional
intelligence the people skills and
you're deploying it against the
technology and operations business my
intuition not best in supplies if you're
making a mistake you're making a mistake
let me tell you what mistake you're
making you're letting other people do it
for you I'm doing it for myself
if I went as good-looking as new I have
11 million [ __ ] followers do not
listen I can all do myself
do not let so
I know I know I'm right you're deploying
your energy against something that has
no shot of winning in my opinions none
and I know like the truck and like it's
not fun for me to say that but I could
be wrong I've been wrong before
let's keep everything you know I'm not a
[ __ ] genie but my intuition is we are
now in the Europe where guys like you
don't have to be at the mercy of MTV
it's the golden gear of that and and and
and you're doing two things wrong first
you're deploying your magic against
something that you shouldn't and then
number two in the place where you have
the magic you're trying to let somebody
else control your outcome because what
you have is not something that can be
bought what you need to do is you need
to bring all that energy and you need to
do
you should become a reality TV star on
Facebook Instagram snapchat and YouTube
you should block your life your dating
life your homies life the basketball
life your [ __ ] buying sneakers life
you personally will make over a million
dollars a year
[Music]
I'm doing the best thing ever I've so
many sneakers here no longer speakers in
my class have been on a lot of work kind
of giving way to random people and I put
on the duo I mean one during ten and a
half
anybody want boots turn up ten and a
half Colin ten and a half everybody just
run and a half look you don't are you
out of your mind
I'm not supposed to do any red eyes now
you want we do red eye connectors week
the grass
[Music]
yeah finally
real pleasure to talk about hustle we
talk a lot about ride remember what they
see a lot of is that a lot of students
going to want to hop a lot
we're striking on the cone their
attention is somewhere else and there
seems to be this misnomer that as long
as I get a really good SAT score I'll go
to that College of my choice and then
whatever the comments was if everything
to be okay yeah I mean that's a it's a
it's a misnomer
misnomers and stereotypes and things
like that or grounded in truths
there was a time in day and age there is
no like there was no conversation when
we went through k12 where there was any
outlet other than the variable of your
success was going to be predicated on
what college you went to I was making
real money like you know like real money
I was making a thousand two thousand
three thousand dollars a weekend as a 12
13 14 15 year old and there was nobody
in my life outside of my parents who
deemed that as a proxy or a preview to
success that is infinite so let's just
say that you know if we're all this
virtually watching your blogs and less
is part of class once again the hard
part is the collaboration and the work
so I don't necessarily think we're all
going to stay at home and watch the
video tutorials I don't think that's how
our budding thing together is powerful
however if Gary were to transform a
let's just go with middle school or high
school what is the first thing you start
with well I think the first thing I
start with is I mean it's you know it's
funny how many different place in my
brain one one the place in my brain when
this first I got to get people to send
their kids there so it's about the
marketing of what the [ __ ] I'm up to
right but if you're saying that's all
done and if you're talking more about
the curriculum or the execution of what
are we actually doing there the first
thing we do is we memorize the zero
information ever forever it's rule
number one of the Bill of Rights of my
schools zero zero memorization of
information informations commoditized
it's at the fingertips of every single
person memorizing and knowing any
information is diction it's out it's
outlawed it is not valued we do not
score on it you know I think I think the
first thing I build an entrepreneur
whoa and so the first class in the first
day is all about selling every selling
is you know the seed in a lot of ways of
entrepreneurship I feel like you know
not everybody's a cyclic so I fell but I
sell by building brand and letting
people come to me right I hate like
asking somebody to buy something right I
don't like the feeling of not having the
leverage so I think the first thing
would be teaching a selling class so
probably the first day of school given
my narrative of my career would be
lemonade 101 and everybody would kind of
walk in and depending on if it was a
middle school I would still call it
lemonade but we would probably do is we
would buy and sell something most likely
we would go right so my curriculum would
change every year my concepts would
change every year but it would be a 100%
doing organization right let me teach
something on Monday and we would do it
literally Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and
Friday and then and then some version of
that I don't know if that goes another
week or if every Monday I'm willing to
teach something but four or five days is
doing and so day number one today if it
started Amaro is retail retail arbitrage
I believe every single person listening
to this can make $100,000 a year 100
thousand dollars a year and had very
good work-life balance by buying stuff
in one place and selling it on the
internet somewhere else
one people revise to that seventeen year
old who was really thinking either a gap
year college or not so as far as the 17
year old look I think I think one thing
you should know you have a very long
life ahead of you
it's crazy to me how the human brain
works you never have patience at 17 you
feel like I mean anybody who's 41 to 45
knows that how they felt at 17 that
feels you know like you felt I mean we
were 21 a 41 year old was like almost
dead the oldest [ __ ] of old time and now
we feel like we're 21 still in our
brains maybe we don't look in with a
wrinkle we got the wrinkles now but like
so I think I think the biggest thing I
would tell a seventeen-year-old is you
have so much time it's actually
laughable
so make a decision whether gap year of
college
or not
completely predicated on realizing that
your life is so long you have so much
time you can probably make nothing but
mistakes for the next 13 years of your
life and probably still have a
tremendously happy life and once you
wrap your head around that it probably
empowers you to make the best decision
for yourself
appreciate you being a New Age teacher
thank you don't example thank you thank
you so much love you yeah take care
1001 p.m. I'm going to a dinner meeting
iris wanted me to say something before I
went to my dinner meeting
there you go iris
[Music]